hello and welcome to video playing boom
boskie hola
bimbo sky we don't know bimbo sky sounds
really weird so yeah but can I do play
the Pogo I came so we transpose into
endings of Indian style of a set up the
smile line against it always been quite
happy with this many people still play
Queen d3 which is not very testing you
should be - as some a lot um I think a
lot more problematic Quincy Quincy - is
actually interesting this is displayed
we take pancake and castles I think YUM
this is some quite dangerous I don't
quite remember what I recommended let's
castle first I mean what I recommended
in my book
I know it has some compensation you
absolutely
so airplane if possible d6 + e5 would
help simply to kill off the bishop okay
maybe c5 now for white yeah
okay if I take that's not it's really
not convenient it takes only five and I
don't see a really great moose then okay
giving up I'm giving back this pond for
the moment does he have something really
like brilliant like not moving this I
don't quite don't quite believe it but
you never know
yeah stuff like that that's what I was
thinking about I can't go f6 this is the
biggest problem that's what I would love
to do if he takes with the night yeah
then I think I can I can take the cake
take this quite reasonably
she takes on c6 now what about Queen d1
check
Queen d1 Bishop f1 Bishop h3 that is
[Music]
winning
it's got 97 Bishop g7 just check no yeah
I think that what was winning in fact so
what what's going on now I mean exchange
up but he still has pretty active pieces
so 55 maybe threatened no it doesn't
react to it if I do that now is going
Queen g4
but then I have Queen to g6 yeah okay
trading one bishop here is helpful and
we go from there
I don't see a really good move from her
white hand in this position queen F for
something although this one okay um
anything better than taking I don't
think so let's take and now on the night
might come to see five
where do I put all all this 36.4 25
that's it's still not super easy to win
because he is still quite active now
though the pieces that he has are good
23 hour play 95 tending nygean I have
six regrouping yeah okay I cannot take
it but yeah I guess the specter of six
it would be very helpful if you had to
play e3 you know because now the night
is not stable anymore
Nydia one rookie one should win let's
see I can check here
it doesn't window surprisingly
threatening rook takes a one
okay got 39 seconds left and everything
is protected
yeah so let's have a look there that was
interesting it was an interesting
opening choice
Quincy tool is a largely unexplored move
but during my when I wrote the book I
discovered that this move is quite
interesting and I don't exactly remember
what I recommend that really don't do I
think I do now when I see the engine
yeah this is what the engine gives so I
played this quintics it's also a 3 and
94 even this is a move and then I
remember this line which is looking
really strange but he United 3 was good
I think
one night see - I don't quite remember
oops
that's it - and then going back this was
or this one this was ok ok he took money
for with the Queen I took him cancelled
cancelled a3 and now I should grab I
know I don't know about a three rookie
one yeah a three is kind of a useless
moment I'm really not certain white has
some this some questionable pawn
structure if I get in d6 and get some
stability then I'm a lot better and this
is this is a bit the problem here now I
think I'm very safe probably due to c5
this move isn't really great it's what I
want to do if I've but maybe cannot do
Knight a5 or Bishop d7 yeah it's very
sensible we had to complete development
first yeah I didn't see c5 so this is
why I'm and you see if he doesn't play
that I'm very much better so I
overlooked a critical move yeah default
I like this a lot better than taking but
the
shaking is fine okay let's do this
and Bishop e6 and here I expected him to
play this one f6 and then Knight h4 that
was what I was thinking but I felt I
should be fine I mean not better but
okay
he played roop d6 after which I probably
have to play route 88 and now Knight X
was a bit of a shocker I don't think it
works at all you know I'm taking the
material I hope I didn't belong to
anything very stupid but it felt quite
quite controlled yeah I think it was a
reasonable game okay guys thanks for
watching